good I'm ready no cover the hot salt
okay what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we open up season 4 with Cara
Delevingne she's the two-time model of
the year turned Hollywood star you know
her from films like Paper Towns and
Suicide Squad we can catch her in her
latest movie valerian in the city of a
thousand planets coming to theatres July
21st Caryl welcome to the show thank you
very much for having me how are you a
spicy food I'm not great to be honest
but this is gonna be fun because you're
gonna see me suffer which is always good
all right well you ready to get started
yes
[Music]
all right so this first one is Valentina
Valentina is not big deal okay that's
guy that was like good spicy mm-hmm I'm
into that one you once said that if you
were rich enough you'd start a music
label and given your love of poetry and
artists like Kendrick Lamar and Eminem
my gasps is that you favor the lyricist
who's your top five that are alive
lyricist Dead or Alive oh my god that's
so hard I think you said two of them
right there kind of tomorrow and Eminem
I'm notorious b.i.g I'm gonna go for
Queen and Bob Dylan
I'm ready into Valentino so maybe I like
spicy food all night long I might take
some of that's been live it's someone
who's been multiple times can you give
me one do and one don't when it comes to
surviving Burning Man a lot of people
prepare a lot of different outfits for
Burning Man but to be honest at
somewhere you can go and just be naked
because you are the desert so don't
worry too much about what you're gonna
wear
don't forget food and water because
again you are in a desert I'm from
England and have never been in like a
desert climate before so it definitely
took me a while to handle them for sure
what's the weirdest thing you saw last
time he went I think in the middle of
the pie at some point I saw two people
having sex but I wasn't sure if it was
an art piece or not
oh you like it yeah so far I feel like
we're three for three is ready good
isn't all Vulcan Antigua well aardvark
is actually kind of a poetic segue into
this question because I know that you're
a wild animal lover and you've worked
alongside a tarantula snakes tiger a
bear Komodo dragon which one is the most
memorable experience I think well sharks
yeah
well sharks Komodo dragons are pretty
cool
I know if the treasure was a real
beavers well so yeah if you could work
with any animal that you haven't already
what would it be oh that's such a good
question I've done a she with a snake
was I gonna say an elephant yeah it's
fancy it's fancy
I like that no I like the ginger no not
if you had to put money on it which
would you say is your better game call
of duty or Grand Theft Auto probably
grab that dodo because I've played it so
much and I've spent hours just lost in
that world I cannot wait for the new Red
Dead Redemption to come out that's gonna
be a time consuming thing and then I
know that you go by car Adele when
you're playing call of duty does anybody
ever connect the dots and figure out who
you are while you're playing yeah I used
to play live a lot and I'd be playing
you know zombies or something with you
know a couple of like fourteen-year-old
boys or something obviously they didn't
know who I was but they would always
think I was another 15 oldboy which was
very funny trying to persuade the layers
actually 22 year old girl do you think
that you're probably the best
first-person shooter that's everyone
model of the years GG low-key kind of
deadly with the sticks I mean I hope so
but I'm open for a challenge and he
wants to take me on it down there hasn't
been one I don't like it gets a little
hairy over here
yeah like warning signs of it so we have
a recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham and what we do is we
do a deep dive and I guess Instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger story
does that sound good okay alright laptop
please this is fun oh that one's gonna
kick at the end a little bit
ha yeah good good good first up what's
going on here so that's me tattooing
Margo's toes with Tomo G's which is what
we made up for emojis on our toes we
both had them on our feet um and behind
me is Margaret's stunt double walking in
which is why it looks like markers
behind me but even they thought so too
so it was basically like an emoji face
it was just like a smiley face um I had
five of them she had one or two I think
and then two you have a lion tattooed on
you you have a snake of all the animal
tattoos that you have which one's the
most important to you probably the
elephant which is this one cuz I got it
from my grandmother but she passed away
because there was a favored animal all
right I have one more for you car
brushing your teeth over FaceTime with
Tyler the Creator yeah I think I was
shooting Paper Towns I was in North
Carolina I love those local gate
toothbrushing things and of course
whenever I brush my teeth a face I'm
kinda I think I have mine in my mouth
and then I think he got out his to
freshen that was the beginning of our of
our toothbrush loves of a proud
tradition yeah
wait well so this next one is dirty
dicks
you got some Brittany and another
chef-driven one oh my god love it hmm
that's I've got a sweet beginning pace
mm-hmm
some of these including ours you'll put
like a citrus blend or some sort of
fruit blend in because then it kind of
Trojan horses and the heat yeah so you
get that taste a little bit and then it
lights up your mouth afterwards I like
that I love daddy Dave's mmm nobody
opening me up to these hot sauces guys
you're getting into it already
appreciate that one set first we feast
were obsessed with what people eat and
is a famed world traveler I'm sure you
have a unique perspective what's the
most overrated celebrity sighting
restaurant and why is it no who don't
don't don't trash-talk Nobu okay I love
no you're a Nobu oh I love no good come
on it's so good you know the crispy
shrimp with that like icon I won't go
into no good forever rapid four novels I
mean obviously Nobu isn't the best
Japanese restaurant but it is something
I don't know I love that you're an
apologist what's your favorite
after-hours snack to share with kendall
Jenner she makes them really mean
macaroni cheese
what is the British meal that you miss
when you're traveling by I can't feel my
lips well what's the British meal that
you miss when you're traveling um I love
a good Sunday roast just like roast
chicken mashed potatoes my family secret
gravy I miss that you know just having
Sunday touch with my family also English
too incredible Indian food just sounds
ridiculous tikka masala yeah I can't
hear you of my lips it's funny like you
know go [ __ ] him go through
so this next one is the apocalypse for
ramping it up here
I can't taste anything anymore that's
probably a competitive advantage in
their game like this or maybe you can Oh
No she's gonna come I can buy anything
else literally alright so you've been in
this industry since you are a teenager
which much like an athlete puts you in a
unique position of having to grow up
fast while simultaneously not really
having the chance to turn up I'm sorry
I'm I'm sure that in many ways you're
wise beyond your years but is there
something where you're still woefully
helpless your most immature where you
arrested in development um I don't know
I I'm very easily distracted I also love
to distract people you know I enjoy life
and I love to laugh at things and that
you know I hate it when me or someone
else takes themselves too seriously so I
90 no ruffle people's feathers a bit but
you know sometimes that can obviously
ruffle people's that little item so okay
I can feel it now these on the
apocalypse is creeping up here
all right so this next one is the bomb
beyond insanity Cara how you doing
sweating so that's cool thanks for that
guys hot ones always a show we have to
apologize for
I can already oh no way gotcha yeah are
you mad
how do people do that for fun I'm gonna
cry I don't think anybody doesn't he
does it for fun my friends who love hot
sauce
sunny miles hello you would you like
down these bottles I can't even breathe
Hogan to laugh at me now I'm a hot sauce
can I have some melon milk yeah yeah go
go with whatever you want go with
whatever you want trying to smoke you
out here karl lagerfeld once called you
the Charlie Chaplin of the fashion world
and you've made untold headlines
[Music]
for famous photo bombs and practical
jokes would see a last elaborate prank
that you found yourself having to
apologize for oh let me think about it I
don't know I don't play enough practical
jokes any wolves I'm about to go on a
press tour with my wonderful team over
there about to get it really hard though
I'll let make sure that I tag you
somehow so you can see what I do do you
think you could do anything with the
bomb and who would you prank are the
wheels turning it all for you I mean
really slowly cuz there's so much spice
in my mouth that I can't feel the rest
of my face but um this is what the
weekend wrote all about right consoles
surely um yeah I'm thinking of something
it doesn't help makes it was I think I
think you're just in a place it's just a
quicksand situation
you're trapped on this show yes I hear
out from the junket that there's a light
at the end of the tunnel with no you
just run into hot ones yeah you ready
do I have to I mean no like what about
what are you gonna do get arrested I
mean you can tap out if I can tap out I
don't have anything is it get worse
though these gears are a less safe yours
I would say cards yeah calm your nerves
a little bit
- bomb is probably the one with the
sharpest bar though it's hardest to
hurdle yeah
we're in an order but I think that this
one's the hardest mm-hmm
I want to dive into the almond milk I
want to live in it I never want to get
out it's anyone in coconut oil they can
rub on my face god I'm really not cover
uh-huh
[Music]
so gonna keep sipping on my helmet okay
what about if I eat them both at the
same time because I feel like this
breaks that I'm taking in between it's
killing me but but what if you're wrong
about that no I can tell that you're
lying to me no I've never seen anyone do
it and I just don't want to feel any
sense of like I played a role in all
right so this one is Blair's Megadeth
sauce but if I kept my mouth open I'd be
drooling all over the floors how hard it
is a member imagine being me no what are
you doing don't do that to yourself you
got a little schmutz mmm Welsh
Montenegro I'll get it
what if I just lick them yeah
listen there are no rules I feel like
I'm gonna get in trouble with the whole
schools community I mean yeah they do
they get fired up oh but I mean what do
you have to prove to the hot sauce
community that I have Holtz those bulls
well there's only one way to do it and
that's by taking a bite out of that will
ya
which one's was Megadeth all hot ones
[Music]
dony meeny miny on cable I should
probably finish with this one yeah it's
the last dab on a structural level if
we're moving along you do want to go
with the death sauce first
I think it'll I think it's still bonding
mm-hmm Wow I'm impressed
okay you're good you're good
you're killing it you're killing it Carl
all right so your eyebrows they've
inspired countless fan accounts and
they've even been blamed for decline and
tweezer sales according to Google so as
of growl enthusiasts what I want to do
is show you some of the other most
celebrated iconic brows in popular
culture and I just want to see if you
know who they belong to okay I think
that you're good for 3 out of 5 I would
be impressed before out of 5 I would be
blown away by 5 out of 5 I love the
spike got it yep
[Music]
the rock the people's eyebrow the three
were too easy I knew that this I knew it
would I knew oh oh oh like that guy
she's in the NBA that's what I knew
possible Anthony Davis I didn't know you
know you like you're impressed by the
beautiful eyebrows real nice confident
Jennifer Aniston that's you that's you
Helmick yeah dude I'm like what's the
name huh all right so this last one is
the last dab it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to I
would avoid it if I were you chill Cara
with the shell wait careful it's good
what with Oh on the face yeah but that's
fine you're good at least I put it in my
eye then it'll be over
sorry it's my nose is leaking all over
okay last wing last question if I can
now
[Music]
totally good little mustard action
that's a little chef-driven
I think you'll like it okay Cara you
have one of the most expressive faces in
the movie industry and now that you've
run through ten hot sauces conquered
these violently hot chicken wings I want
you to explain how you feel the feeling
in your mouth
using just facial expressions I'll do it
too and I will start
[Music]
you just made that heat go of my face
that was really amazing it was like I
felt it through you now it's gone how
did you do that that means so much no
it's celeb it's powerful it goes right
through you
yeah there's not a dry eye in the house
here in Para
what an impressive performance 10 wings
up 10 wings down one glass of almond
milk you know how it goes this camera
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on is
anyone's done something like really
crazy like they like drank here or like
put three together in one I put it in my
eye
how about that yeah yeah go for that
okay look at this legend right here I
mean nothing doesn't even touch the
sides how your bowels doing it's you
know you know it's a cross but I bear
for sure that's good so I am in a movie
called valerian and the city of a
thousand planets I really hope you guys
go watch it it's an incredible film
visually the most stimulating thing I've
ever seen about as stimulating is what
I've just done to my mouth right now
I'm gonna drink somewhere else oh my god
okay do you have any coconut hole no
okay is anyone the Oh yep oh wow hello
world Sean Evans coming at you to say
thank you for watching if you like what
you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the 3000th ranked
youtube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please jk jk no
pressure but if you do subscribe I
appreciate it